[Music]
Republican convention has been on the
final night been on all week and we
wanted to send a correspondent a lot of
shows send a correspondent we want to do
that so we sent one of our writers mr.
Deon Cole there is cover the convention
well less demand things went badly for
Deon from the get-go true story this is
absolutely true on Monday night before
their RNC even started Deon had his
credentials taken away and was banned
from the convention why because he
thought it would be fun to duck under a
rope run up onstage and tell a joke from
the podium without getting anyone's
permission first well unfortunately this
Secret Service guy wasn't amused and
Deon was thrown out now luckily by
Wednesday Deon had new credentials to
get back inside thanks to his cousin
Marvin who makes fake IDs
[Applause]
his head in the yellow pages
yeah so laser Devon were back on track
here's Dion's report from his return
visit inside the Republican National
Convention hey what's happening : n
either being detained and kicked out
days ago I'm here back in
[Music]
about top to speak my see how to
convince it bar told you it can hold a
good man man what's your name
salt Grove Scott saw bro Scott how are
you I'm doing outstanding what type of
change do you think what is the
difference to help their communities
rather than
coming as you see that is the u.s.
national debt counter the first five
numbers that's what I own child support
no I'm gonna run for real
a calling because I little stop Monday
night look what size they put it don't
say me to leave my mind I'm free from
Parkersburg West Virginia Marcus
birthday she was Virginia do you mean
[Music]
down
wonderful they'll enjoy forever Bonnie
yeah I Bob better just make enough
states does it bother you that Mitt
Romney spent less money on taxes that
you did on your haircut I have a great
deal like Bob only tied to $7 a haircut
can we just ask you one question two
words that haven't been said here that
most people are far too scared to say
yeah George Bush I think a lot of things
that they really don't want to hear
again is don't worry elect me there's
hope and change that's what they don't
want to
[Applause]
does anyone have an extra Bearcat
what about suspended in funky in RC come
dancing for two hours and that one white
person want to come dance with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
seriously they follow me through the
place and kick me out again so hopefully
you got what you needed this is Deion
Cove signing off from Tampa Florida a
place I would never ever come again
[Applause]